Celine Dion has the turning heads in
Europe with her style and her new
thinner look and now she is ready to
clear the air starting with her love
life is Celine really dating her backup
dancer
Kevin you know when I say I am single
please leave me alone I don't want to
talk to pay pay but it's probably maybe
sometimes difficult for him yeah this is
another man in my life but not the man
in my life I don't mind because he's
handsome and he's my best friend
[Music]
so basically Selene doesn't care what
anyone thinks that 50 years old she's
unapologetically living life on her own
terms love you Selena and she's been
taking Paris Fashion Week by storm in
the process while some people have
criticized her new look and
boundary-pushing style Selena told the
UK show Lorraine she's not having any of
it they really wanted to be in shape as
much as I can
sometimes people would say oh whoa whoa
whoa that was a little limb maybe a
little much don't take a picture we'll
keep it for the other if you like I'll
be there if you don't leave me alone
this past week Selene also celebrated a
huge milestone for eldest son Rene
Charles just heard a teen while this is
what he told ET and 2017 now I'll just
call him by his rap names big Tim you
better appreciate the greatness before
I've got one too yeah Victor well he
does stuff sometimes that I have to say
not necessarily agree with what I but
I'm very very proud of him yeah it's a
baby
[Music]